The father of a New Jersey.
14 year old girl
who died
by suicide is demanding justice
this morning.
Adriana Cooke
was found dead
in her home on February 3rd,
just two days
after a video was posted online
showing her
being beaten and attacked
at Central Regional High in Bellville.
There's a clip of it there.
We're not showing it to you
because, listen, it's just disturbing.
The story is awful.
Adriana's father believes
her suicide was fueled by long time
bullying.
CNN's Brendan Grass
has been following this story.
So the four teenagers
who allegedly dumped her in the hallway,
this they're facing criminal charges.
The superintendent resigned yeah.
What more happened here?
All within a week.
And as Jim said,
we're not going to show you the video,
but I do want to describe it to you.
So you get a better sense.
And you guys that,
you know, as parents,
it just makes you angry, honestly.
Basically, it shows this high school
freshmen walking down the hallways
of her high school with her boyfriend.
When four people approach them,
they throw some sort of liquid at her
and then basically take her to the ground
and start beating her
until school
officials intervene
and break up that fight.
Now, the father of Adriana Couch
says that the school
then just sent her to the nurse,
didn't call authorities.
They did suspend those students,
but that was it.
And he says he's
the one
who actually took her
to the police department
to file a police report.
Then this video comes out of the incident
that's gone all over social media.
He gives that to the authorities.
I want you to hear from him more
about how he describes the video.
And then we'll talk more
They think it's fun
to attack people
and make videos and post them
cheap lax out.
And they don't call an ambulance.
They take her to the nurse's office.
Adriana was
the most happy,
beautiful young lady in the world.
Now, the school says that
they did alert authorities as they said
those students were suspended.
They've also been charged.
One is charged with aggravated assault.
But the point here, guys,
is that this whole entire
community is up in arms
because they say
this isn't a one time incident.
There is a culture of bullying.
The school says now
that the superintendent has resigned,
they're going to go back
and look at these past allegations
of bullying with other students.
They're going to consult
with the school district
and the Department of Education
and how they reform their policies.
But it's horrific.
I mean, this girl took her own life
two days
after this
cyber bullying
incident was posted online.
We talk about the online hate
and harassment
that these teenagers
have to go through all the time.
And, you know, it's just horrific.
14 years old.
It's awful.
And as poor family
now mourning their daughter
and also having to deal
with everything that led up to this.
Yeah, there's no words to it.
A loss for words. Brant, thank you.
Thank you.
Well, to that point
this morning, a new study
highlights that not enough
young people are getting adequate
mental health services.
That study finds
nearly half of children
who go to the E.R.
with a mental health crisis
do not receive the follow up
care that they need.
CNN senior medical correspondent
Elizabeth Cohen is with us.
So I would imagine
that health professionals
do see this as a growing problem.
I guess the question is,
is there an answer to it?
Are there the resources
right?
The answer
is going to be so tough, Erica.
So we all know that
when you are treating someone
for a mental health issue,
they need to have ongoing treatment.
A visit to the emergency room
is not enough.
So these researchers
looked at nearly
30,000 children
who had a visit to the emergency room
for a mental health issue.
A lot of times it was depression.
Sometimes it was a trauma
related mental health disorder.
And what they found was it didn't
the follow up did not go so well.
What they found
is that seven days after only about 31%
in that week following the E.R.
discharge,
only 31% of them
had some kind of a follow up visit.
And if you take a look at a month later.
So in other words, lots and lots of time
to have a follow up visit.
Only 56% of them did.
How in the world
are we expecting to treat our children
with mental health disorders?
And we know
that the number of children
with mental health issues
is rising all the time.
How can we treat them
if we can't get them care?
So there are several issues going on.
One is just poor access to care.
There aren't enough people out there
to treat the children
or the adults, for that matter,
who need help
with mental health disorders. Also.
This study found
something really disturbing
but not surprising.
Black children had a much harder time
getting that follow up care.
Erica, Jim.
Goodness, they need help.
I feel like we cover stories
like this nearly every day.
Elizabeth Cohen,
thanks for highlighting it for us.